as long as it gets you drunk who gives a
[ __ ] how much I'm a garbage person who
drinks garbage wine so when you put
something nice and fancy in front of me
my palate is gonna know I just recently
started to get into wine that's why I
had was some rich person's house on
Thanksgiving I went there after my
Thanksgiving where we had normal wine my
biggest fear is that I have the $199 and
it's delicious and then I spend all my
money buying expensive line and I ruin
my own life I ought to be able to tell
which one is the cheap wine
oh this I know this wine I know it I
took one sip and I was like mmm
I don't think that's good and then I
swallowed him I was like maybe it's
really good it doesn't have that attack
the tongue sort of bitterness to it does
it this noise we have a breakup I had
once I'm rubbing it on my chapped lips
and they don't hurt that means low
acidity I'm tasting like children's
juice I think I know what is it smoo 99
to vile Chuck why I have real chatter
Jose you know what this could be
expensive this is cheap right now I'm
saying $2
I already feel like this one's more
expensive because it's darker it had
like a fuller color oh my it's got some
legs look at those legs made my mouth
what a coup in reaction to it it's not
very smooth which makes me think it's
either one ninety or ninety ninety nine
you know this could be expensive this is
more familiar to me I've never had a
cheap wine taste like this this one is
the most expensive one I can see a wine
connoisseur liking the bitterness of it
but that bitterness to me also makes me
think that it could be very cheap it
sounds super weird I I keep on the train
because I don't understand it all wine
Oh baby oh what's that oh this is
definitely the expensive wine there I
don't know this smell like this is the
news it smells like butter
Oh other some smells the best it's off
sniff yeah I think is the middle of the
pack so this is either the bottom shelf
or it's like the middle but wouldn't it
be crazy because it's so bad if it were
the most expensive I'm calling it this
is expensive has the smell of berry
strawberries raspberries it's very
complex my taste so that immediately it
was like I think this one's the bad one
one of these wines it's turn of dollars
that is great that's great I think this
one wasn't $199 one cup I think that
this one was a $1.99 one I think this
one right here was the 19.99 seven the
first one is the expensive one $1.99 the
second one is that cheap one and then
the last one is the middle to 2100
midpoint $20 cheapest most expensive
right so you got it all right who does
this life but I do think I liked this
one the most but that's also cuz like I
have a cheap palette $19.99
thunder $99 night 99999 presentation
mattered yes like my mind so consciously
decided that one of these I was nicely
presented would be more expensive we
know it we drink this is our this is
what runs through my veins does the cost
really denote taste I think it's kind of
up to you
[Music]